To get back to the rendering Pipeline, our simplified view is this. The
Application sends a triangle to the GPU. The GPU determines where the triangles
vertices are on the screen, including the z-depth. Each pixel inside the
triangle is shaded. If the pixel passes the z-buffer test It is then saved to
the image and displayed at the end of the frame. Modern GPUs have parts of the
Pipeline that are Programmable. The transformed screen part of the Pipeline is
done by what is called a Vertex Shader. This Programmable element, essentially a
little computer, processes each Vertex of the triangle. The Vertex Shader uses
information provided to it to manipulate each Vertex in some way. For example,
the color of the triangle at this point could be computed, or the vertexes
position could be modified, if, for example, you wanted to have an object
inflate or explode. One operation the vertex shader always does is to output a
location of the vertex on the screen. The second half of our modern GPU
Pipeline, we represent here by two stages. Triangle set up in the Fragment
Shader. Triangle set up uses the three screen locations generated by the Vertex
Shader for an incoming triangle. This forms a triangle in screen space. Each
pixel covered by part of the triangle has what is called a Fragment generated
for it. This process is called scan conversion. The Fragments generated are sent
to the Fragment Shader. Well if you used Microsoft's Direct X API, this is
called the Pixel Shader instead. The Fragment Shader is provide information by
the triangle being processed. Some to the Vertex Shader the programmer can also
feed in any other data desired. The Fragment Shader runs a program that
typically a Color an a Z Depth value. This Z Depth value is then tested against
the Z buffer as usual. If the surface is visible, the color is saved for that
Pixel. The shade Pipeline is designed to compute the Color at each Pixel the
surface covers. That's it's ultimate purpose after all, creation of an image.
Everything done in the Pipeline comes down to this. How DO WE EFFICIENTLY
CALCULATE THIS COLOR? That's what the last half of this unit is about, materials
and how they work. Given a material and some incoming light you want to compute
a Color off that material.